where were you when you got the call or
the information about this suppose at
audition for this Duracell Powermat with
cheese oh man it was at house casting in
New York down in the West Village and I
had an audition for this commercial
Duracell Powermat commercial featuring
jay-z I went to the first audition and
it was just me you know with the cast
director going over this scene where I
hand the phone there's some type of
awkward moment that happens I was like a
sweet audition I'll never forget it
just because it didn't seem like it was
my type I saw the other other actors in
the room and and it just didn't seem
like I don't I just did I didn't feel
like I was gonna get this role you know
yeah it's weird some it's weird how
sometimes you feel that and then those
are the ones that you booked it's crazy
I get a call and like you got a callback
for the duracell I'm like okay cool my
agent you know called me I went back and
there was anthony mandler anthony
mandler is one of the biggest music
video and creative directors in business
in Los Angeles he shot all of Katy
Perry's music video music videos a lot
of Lana Del Rey and raised musically
tears I had no idea this guy was but he
had the he sits there and abused me and
the callback went well and I got a call
like the next thing like you booked to
her cell and I didn't really hit me
until I was on set you know like a week
later and jay-z is there in the room and
we're doing scene together I was I was
like what you know I don't get
starstruck I really don't I see actors a
lot and then you know you meet a lot of
celebrities out here in New York but
jay-z is a force man that guy is just I
mean who wouldn't want to be jay-z music
clothing I mean he just he owns a
basketball team the guy who was the man
I was a little star-struck but he was
really cool talk to me like a normal
dude and that's what I think's great
about he was humble but I was thinking
later I mean he can be humble he doesn't
have a worry in the world he's married
to a beautiful well you know a beautiful
girl beautiful talented girls get all
the money
it's like why does he have to he doesn't
need to be you know conceited or cocky
at all because he's got it
you know just the charming awesome guy
very
and I took I was able to take the money
from a that I made from those
commercials and was able to move to Los
Angeles so now you realize how much
money you can make from these national
commercials they're pretty awesome so
hopefully I booked another one soon they
weren't a buyout what no no no most most
national network side Union commercials
that are not buyouts so do you remember
being on set like how many hours and oh
yeah we shot the whole day the
commercial it's funny jay-z's only in
about three or four seconds of a
commercial I'm in like like three
quarters of it which is crazy it's
basically just a camera following me
around the city with my cool power mat
charger you know being cool and you know
sending texts and being a city guy I
think they had me being like graphic
designer they had me in these cool
clothes
I still have clothes from that shoot I
still wear them because that was the
epitome of me being cool and they let me
keep some of the clothes I still rock
some of those outfits but they had they
followed me around New York and then we
get to the club and the whole scenario
is I accidentally pick up jay-z's phone
pick it up and it says B is calling him
what B and then jay-z comes in he's like
I'm like oh very funny
awkward Roman in the commercial did well
and yeah it was cool to say now I was in
that it was really grateful to be in it
so do people recognize you um a few
people not not many because they're you
know they're paying attention to jay-z
it's not like when you're watching the
commercial like who's this guy
and then they see Jay it's like Oh
jay-z's in that commercial they're not
really remembering the guy that's
handing the phone but you are in like
you said there's good three quarters oh
yeah that's awesome but jay-z Michael
Galante if I have one 90th of his power
and force you know that the height of my
career I will die happy man
you